welcome to the session on how to connect
react.js with no Jess and in this
session we are actually going to look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an Express GS application with no GS and
we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so Express
GS is a rapid application development
framework that allows us to create a web
application very quickly on the node.js
platform and will use it to create a
custom API and then connect that
endpoint to the react GS client
application so let's dive into our demo
and let's start with creating our client
and node Express applications and see
how to set them up and then get them
connected to each other let's start with
our hands-on demo and we will first go
to the node.js website nodejs dot o-r-g
we can download the NTS version which is
the stable version of node.js moment I
click on this it will prompt you for a
download it will download the MSI file
and then all I need to do is double
click on it keep clicking on the next
button and install that would install
node.js for us next we'll open our
editor you can use any editor of your
choice so I'm going to use an editor
called Visual Studio code and let's open
up the terminal here and I also have the
command prompt open where I have
navigated to a folder that I've created
called react GS demos now we will invoke
the NPM package manager which is invoked
by the command NP x so npx will not only
in
stole packages but also execute them
once they are installed so once they are
downloaded it will execute the package
and we will use npx to go and create a
react application called client so while
we give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it within our
editor so we'll give it time
so that the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we have seen here that the installation
is now completed and let's go and open
up this project so I will say file and
open folder and let me pick up that
folder and we will open this application
called flight so that's my client app
let's fire up the terminals so ok so
that has launched the terminal for us
and here all we need to do to fire up
this application and get it running is
NPM start which will compile and start
up this application that is created
let's close this we go to the browser
and now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us a startup page the sample
default startup page for the first
client application and this is going to
work as a client will now go and try to
create the back-end application which is
going to be another application that we
will set up and to create that let's say
npx Express generator API ok so this
will create an Express application on
node.js called
API and let's give it some time for
installation okay so that's done clear
the screen will come out here will open
another instance of the editor we will
say open folder and that's the API
application we will say select folder
and the API application is opened let's
go to the terminal now in the terminal
we will attempt to install all of the
packages that are required that would be
logged in the package store JSON file so
the package dot JSON file here would be
a listed as so you can see we have a
list of packages that it uses and NPM
install we'll go and install all of
these packages that were relisted here
so let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we fire that once more that's done
so NPM install has installed all of the
packages required and let me terminate
this run by pressing a ctrl C so this
terminates the client application that
was executing and now we will say NPM
start so that this application executes
and let's refresh so that's the standard
Express application now that has got
installed now let's go to the API
application we'll go into the bin folder
and here we'll have a file called www we
will change the default port number from
3,000 to 9,000 let me stop this
application from executing we've just
updated the port number now let's go to
the routes and we'll create a new file
in the routes folder called test API dot
GS here we will say variable Express
equal to require Express and here we
will say variable router equal to
Express dot router and here we will say
router dot get we'll open this so that's
the default route route route is going
to be slash for which we lad a callback
function which will take the request and
the response parameter and next pointer
in case there is another function to
call post that and here we will just
send a simple message saying API is
working a simple message sent out for
the route default route and we'll have
to export this so we will say module dot
exports equal to router all right so
that's done let's go to the app dot J's
file and here let us import that so here
is where we will import this by saying
app dot use we want to use the test API
file and that is test API router and
this is exactly the same variable name
that we will declare here which will be
equal to require and we are going to say
routes test ABI alright so let's try
launching this now we would say NPM
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3,000 tests
API is going to be the URL to hit it's
not 3000 but 9000 now because we just
update
did the port so 9,000 test API and there
we have a message which says that the
API is working properly so this is
tested now let's go to the client
application in the client application
let's go to the app dot GS file okay
this is the file that we would have to
revamp a bit so let's revamp this here
we we will declare a glass app which
extends so that creates a new module so
it extends react dot component and here
we have constructor we will accept the
props here I would pass props to the
superclass constructor and set the state
to API response currently it just has an
empty value next we light up a new
function called call API which will
generate a call to that API URL which
was HTTP localhost 9000 was the port and
test API was the URL once this is called
we will then call the den function
declare response generate a call to
response dot text and then we will again
say this dot set state API response is
going to be equal to the response that
comes in from that URL which is nothing
but a string which says API is working
another function called component will
mount so the moment the component is
initialized on the screen and loaded we
will generate a call to this function we
created called call ABI
then comes the render function in the
render function we would go and return a
div class name is AB this would be a
better the standard logo after which in
the paragraph we wouldn't need the link
here right after the header we'll add a
paragraph where we will print this dot
state and the variable we created called
API response and we will data bind to
that so that largely completes the
return so we simply create this
application that's the react application
that will talk to the C API that is
and this URL that is hosted on node
communicate with it get a simple string
as a response print that string inside
this react application so once that's
done we have the component will mount
which is a lifecycle method here it's a
new life cycle event that gets trigger
at the moment the component loads and
that's when we have actually gone and
executed the call API custom function
let's go to the API application will
terminate the execution here there's one
more step that we'll have to perform
which is cross-origin resource sharing
which means that to allow the react
application to communicate from another
hosted domain to this particular domain
server we will actually have to enable
cross-origin scripting and sharing
otherwise it will block the request
coming from another application so for
that we'll have to install globally
cross-origin module and - - save
indicates that it's going to do a global
install for all applications that are on
this particular system so we've
installed this and we clear the screen
let's go to the app dot GS and right
here is where we would want it to go in
use chords so we will say app dot use
course so that it uses this particular
API and here is where we will declare
the course variable and who and import
the new library package that we just
installed which is course so looks good
and now let's fire up this application
with an NPM start let's also fire up
client with an NPM start and now when I
go and try looking for localhost 3000
which is the react application the react
application should go and talk to the
API that is hosted on node.js which
returns to me that string message so if
I go and ping that API separately which
is localhost 9000 test API you can see
this is a standard message
so here I've directly ping the API
that's hosted in nodejs now we are
consuming it through the react.js
application
and if you scroll down you can see the
message returned from node.js into react
seeing the API is working properly so
the practical impact of this is to
actually host restful services etc on
node as a server and you can go and
consume the data that is returned there
could be in string text adjacent format
directly into the react GS acting as a
client application finally we'd like to
extend a big thank you for viewing our
content and I hope this has added value
to your learning journey and has been
instrumental in supporting you and
assisting you with learning the right
skills and acquiring the right skills on
this technology to help extend and grow
your career path and your journey way
forward in the industry thank you so
much and a big thank you on behalf of
the CPU on platform hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple
learning YouTube channel and click here
to watch similar videos to nerd up and
get certified click here